[Music]
picture this you were thrown into a
dinky room and told you can't leave
until you have created the thinnest
material known to man not only that it
must also be the strongest the best
thermal conductor and is good at
conducting electricity
as copper I know it sounds hopeless but
luckily you know something about
nanotechnology you know really really
tiny devices and materials that are less
than a hundred nanometers in size of
course I don't have to tell you a
nanometer is a billionth of a meter
that's roughly the size of 10 atoms but
how do you create something that tiny
it's time to embrace your inner MacGyver
you're gonna need a pencil some scotch
tape and a healthy dose of elbow grease
a pencil contains not lead but graphite
which consists of sheets of carbon in a
hexagonal lattice when you write layers
of graphite slide off the tip of the
pencil and stick to the paper usually
many layers are stacked on top of each
other but once in a while you get a
single layer of carbon atoms and this is
called graphene
in 2004 andre game and konstantin
novoselov created graphene using nothing
but graphite and scotch tape they placed
a graphite flake onto the tape folded it
in two and then cleaved the flake in
half they repeated this procedure a
number of times and then studied the
resulting fragments to their
astonishment they found some of the
pieces were only a single atom thick
this was particularly unexpected because
it was thought a single layer of
graphite would not be chemically stable
especially at room temperature graphene
conducts electrons faster than any other
substance at room temperature this is
because of the extraordinarily high
quality of the graphene lattice
scientists are yet to find a single atom
out of place in graphene since the
electrons aren't scattered by defects in
the lattice they go so fast that
Einstein's relativity must be used to
understand their motion and this perfect
lattice is created by the very strong
yet flexible bonds between carbon atoms
making the substance bendable but harder
than diamond graphene is incredibly
strong if you could balance an elephant
on a pencil and support the pencil on
graphene the graphene wouldn't break of
course
the pencil would for their discovery
game and Nova sell-off were awarded the
Nobel Prize for Physics in 2010 and this
is only the beginning for graphene
scientists are hard at work exploiting
its unique properties to create thin
transparent flexible touchscreens
smaller faster more energy efficient
computers tough composite materials
and more efficient solar cells and now
consider this is only one aspect of
nanotechnology so in order to think big
you need first consider the very small
you